-Welcome.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
We are coming to you live
right now from Studio 6A.
After the final debate between
President Trump and Joe Biden,
and I think we can all agree
the winner was Kristen Welker.
I mean, come on.
Knockout.
Home run.
Of course, everyone was
talking about how there would be
a mute button used during
tonight's debate.
It seemed like it
worked pretty well.
I'm thinking of getting one
for Thanksgiving.
The muted mics
really helped, though.
It thought it was much calmer.
At one point, they almost cut to
Jeffrey Toobin
to liven things up.
Yeah, Trump seemed
much more calm.
People were like,
"Did they replace him
with his Disney robot?"
For the most part,
things were pretty civil
compared to the first debate,
which was basically
a UFC fight on meth.
Yeah, it was a lot nicer.
If the first debate was
sponsored by Red Bull,
this one
was sponsored by NyQuil.
Everyone was impressed by Trump
not interrupting or yelling.
I'm not sure it's a great sign
that we talk about the president
like we talk about a 4-year-old
at a puppet show, but...
"You did a great job.
You really did."
That's right -- tonight,
we saw an all-new Trump.
Instead of shouting baseless
accusations, he whispered them.
Trump held in
his anger for so long,
as soon as the debate was over,
he chewed off the armrest
in his limo.
[ Growling ]
Yeah, no one seemed to get
too riled up.
The only person who was really
upset was Chris Wallace.
"Oh, that's how you do it."
And this was fun.
A lot of people played drinking
games during tonight's debate.
If you did a shot every time
Biden said "Come on,"
you were unconscious by 9:15.
[ Mumbling ] Come on!
But tonight's debate
was considered a win
for the Trump campaign,
mostly because he didn't walk in
with a highly
contagious disease.
Actually, they were supposed to
have two Plexiglas barriers
separating Trump and Biden,
but they ultimately
decided against it.
So make that two more walls
Trump couldn't build.
-Ooh!
-Ooh! Ooh!
That's the "ooh"?
I got the "ooh" for that one?
-Ooh-ooh!
Before the debate --
-Ooh!
-Ooh! Oh!
That's my jam.
That's what I do.
I come out,
and everyone goes, "Ooh!
Jimmy, don't hurt 'em."
Before the debate,
it was announced
that Joe Biden tested
negative for coronavirus.
Meanwhile, Trump
is on so many steroids,
he tested positive for
Lance Armstrong.
Heading into tonight, anywhere
between 2% and 8% of Americans
were still undecided.
I just want to say if, after
tonight, you're still undecided,
then, well, we couldn't pick
a joke for this one,
but we'll figure it out
in a week.
Tonight's debate had six
topics -- fighting COVID-19,
national security,
American families,
race in America, climate change,
and whether Rudy Giuliani
was actually tucking in
his shirt.
But after a slow start,
Trump made a lot of accusations
about Biden and his family,
so Joe tried to turn
the conversation to the families
watching at home.
-There's a very strong e-mail
talking about
your family wanting to make
$10 million a year.
-He doesn't want to talk about
the substantive issues.
It's not about
his family and my family.
It about your family.
But that's the last thing
he wants to talk about.
Trump was like, "Trust me --
in our household, it's never
been about my family."
After Trump accused Biden
of wanting to destroy
Social Security and Medicare,
Biden pointed out that
Trump might have the wrong guy.
-Very confused guy.
He thinks he's running
against somebody else.
He's running against Joe Biden.
I beat all those other people
because I disagreed with them.
Joe Biden he's running against.
-Whoa! Biden was fired up.
Trump was like, "Wow.
Give me whatever
steroids he's on."
Later, Kristen Welker asked
if Trump's language
was contributing to a climate
of hate in our country.
Check out what he had to say.
-I am the least-racist person
in this room.
I can't even see the audience
because it's so dark,
but I don't care
who's in the audience.
I'm the least-racist person
in this room.
[ Laughter ]
-Then, instead of
the mute button,
someone hit the laugh track.
It's a little weird to say,
"I'm the least-racist person
in the room"
when half the room
are your friends and family.
It's like,
"He's more racist than I am."
But since this was
the last debate,
both candidates wanted to make
their closing arguments
to the American people.
Let take a look at one of
Trump's closing arguments now.
♪♪
-I know more about wind
than you do.
It's extremely expensive.
It kills all the birds.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-What?
Actually, that's not all.
Trump has been making
closing arguments all week.
Here's another one.
♪♪
-This was caused by Russia.
Russia.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-He's really trying to get
the word out.
Let's see another
closing argument from Trump.
♪♪
-COVID, COVID, COVID, COVID,
COVID, COVID, COVID.
[ Crowd boos ]
COVID, COVID, COVID, COVID.
♪♪
-Do we have any more
closing arguments from Trump?
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
-And with us, as well,
are members of the incredible
Lumbee...Keetoowah...tribes.
Lumbee Keetoowah.
♪♪
-Oh, come on. Okay.
Alright, just one more.
One more.
♪♪
-"What kind of ice cream
are you eating?"
"Uh, chocolate."
♪♪
-Oh, my goodness.
Unbelievable.
Well, Trump had a busy day.
After walking out of yesterday's
interview with "60 Minutes,"
today, he decided to post
the footage early.
I guess he thought it would
help him look better,
but I'm not really sure why.
Watch this.
-No, I'm not.
Well, I'm gonna be fair.
You don't ask Biden
tough questions.
Huh? It's terrible.
It's terrible.
"Are you ready
for tough questions?"
That's no way to talk.
I think we have enough of
an interview here.
Okay? That's enough.
Let's go.
-He's the most powerful man
in the world,
and he spends his time making
bootleg episodes
of "60 Minutes."
Trump tried to embarrass
Lesley Stahl by leaking a video
of her asking tough questions.
Isn't that her job?
Next, he's gonna embarrass
Bobby Flay
by leaking videos of him
making paella.
[ As Trump ]
You just got served, Bobby.
[ Normal voice ]
Also, did you see him
drink the water with two hands?
I'm just glad he's back
to full strength.
Aren't you happy?
How...
[ Applause ]
How is he still drinking water
with two hands?
He's like, "Joe Biden is weak.
[ Slurps ]
He doesn't have the physical
stamina to be president.
[ Slurps ]
Very, very poor health,
Joe Biden."
But this is interesting.
Before tonight's debate,
they announced
a record-breaking number
of people have already voted --
nearly 48 million.
I guess that explains...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I guess that explains why,
three hours ago,
48 million people
tuned into Netflix.
Asked when they made up
their mind,
early voters were like,
"March 2020."
You know Trump
is thinking, "Wow.
48 million people
couldn't wait to re-elect me."
It makes sense that so many
people were able to do it.
Voting is the only
plan we've had
on our calendars
in seven months.
This actually
could be something.
Apparently, NASA
has a big announcement.
Listen to this.
-Apparently, NASA's made
an exciting new discovery
about the moon.
There is a huge announcement
coming from NASA,
but we have to wait
until Monday.
-NASA, you know I love you,
but come on.
We're living through a pandemic.
The last thing we need right now
is a cliffhanger about the moon.
Just tell us.
That's like Dr. Fauci saying,
"I have some exciting news
about the virus
that I'll tell you...
right after the break."
It's 2020, so part of me
is definitely worried
that we're about
to find out that the moon
once partied with
Jeffrey Epstein.
Americans were like,
"Unless it's gonna 'splode,
we do not a-care."
Some sports news.
The NFL just announced that if
games keep getting pushed back
because of COVID,
it could affect
when the season actually ends.
-The NFL acknowledged yesterday
the Super Bowl
could be moved to March if games
keep having to be postponed.
-Yeah, the NFL
told all the players
to keep their schedules open,
except the Jets.
They can start making
other plans.
That's right --
the NFL said the decision
will be made by league
officials, medical experts,
and Patrick Mahomes.
"Yeah, I suppose that time
works for me. Yeah."
Honestly, I don't care.
I lost interest in the NFL once
they cancelled the Pro Bowl.
I mean, why even have a season,
right, guys?
And, finally, a bank in
California had a break-in,
but the thieves
aren't exactly who you'd expect.
Watch this.
-Two masked bandits broke into
a California bank Tuesday,
but they didn't get away
with any cash.
Check out the culprits.
Yeah, they're not bank robbers,
but a couple of raccoons.
-Yeah. Police were like, "Aww,"
until they realized one raccoon
was wanted for triple homicide.
Meanwhile,
another raccoon was outside
hacking into
the security system.
"I just need three more seconds,
and -- Yeah, we're in."
Yep, they're the only ones to
ever break into a bank like,
"Just give us all the trash,
and no one gets hurt"
We have a great show tonight.
Thank you for watching.
We're live here.
Give it up for The Roots.